no not really because again it's an
acceptance thing so I remember you know
doing my master's degree in analytical
chemistry and that involves a lot of you
know somewhat complicated setups with
columns and palms and those and you know
things that you would probably like you
know but for me that that took you know
but even then you know I could spend
hours and hours taking this apart
getting the manual and putting it back
together you knows where other people
would just throw it out the window
period you know so I think you know if
you can accept that at times you know
science can first of all be ninety
percent troubleshooting or it might also
take you three or four years of
discipline to get to the answer no you
know and I think you know people that
have stuck to science they in general
have that mindset if they down there
would be in a very different field if
they need to come home every day was you
know that was my goal i achieved let's
go home